welcome to this free
webinar on bioinformatics for infectious
diseases in today's webinar we will
speak about bioinformatics
for infectious disease research and
present use cases for bioinformatics
analysis methods that are used in viral
evolutionary studies antiviral drug
discovery
as well as the emergence of drug
resistance in bacterial pathogens
we will also showcase some of the latest
developments
on the t bio info platform designed for
virology studies and introduce the
upcoming omics logic training program
for those interested in effective
utilization of bioinformatics
for infectious diseases immunology
and microbiology
as part of our upcoming training program
for students and researchers
with a focus on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
today's webinar will introduce you to
the ways
host pathogen interaction can be studied
using
ngs data analysis
my name is beepsha biswas and
i am the omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are part of our bioinformatics community
managed by pine biotech
over the past couple of years we have
seen participants from all over the
world
join our training programs take online
coursework and utilize
our big data analysis tools in various
research projects
let me start by introducing our company
and collaborators to share with you
details
about the upcoming program
what we will discuss today and
throughout this program is a result of
hard work by an
amazing team led by company co-founders
dr
alfred tauber and
dr tober comes from a medical background
and has extensive expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and has
been recognized internationally for his
generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives that support
training and applications in medicine
dr brodsky is the director of the
childbirth bioinformatics research
center at university of fifa
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career has
developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical
data pardon me uh dr anita
can you cannot see the screen is the
screen visible
no yeah it is it is visible to me
okay can everybody see it
right here already for me as well
okay yes i can see it as well
thank you so much uh for letting me know
yes i can also see the screen
so why not
dr anita if you're having a problem dr
muth if you can just help uh dr anita
i'm sorry everybody uh okay thank you so
much for letting me know
so i'll continue uh with the
presentation now
okay so as i mentioned
under dr brodsky's leadership the topper
research center started collaboration
in research teams at universities like
the university of california
san francisco institute pasture tulane
university and many
others where research labs are working
on cutting-edge research projects
studying
viral and bacterial infections and
designing
novel drugs and vaccines to treat and
prevent
infectious diseases and the rest of the
team that you see here
there are a lot of team members who are
bioinformaticians computer scientists
and we will meet some of them today in
this session
the goal of the omics logic program is
to provide
training in bioinformatics enabling
independent research
guided by mentors and peer example
developing a growing community with
shared passion
for data-driven research and
appreciation of
citizen science enabling students
clinicians and faculty of fallbacks
to develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology in life
and data sciences and i would like to
request everyone to kindly mute yourself
as a presentation is going on so that
every participant can hear the speakers
and the speakers can also interact
with the participants thank you so much
and before we move ahead i would like to
invite you to join our social media
groups
which are there in linkedin and facebook
and i will just
take you to our website so that
you can see these different pages and
groups that we have
and for francis who is asking if you can
record the session the session is
already live
in youtube and you will be able to
review the session
even later on so i'm posting
the links to the groups if you're
already a member of the group
thank you for joining and if you are not
yet a member
you are welcome to come and join these
groups
and secondly i would like to ask
all of you to come with me to edu.t
bioinfo so let me paste that link for
you here in the chat box so once you are
here
please let me know if you already have
an account on edut bio info
we have a step-by-step guide on how to
make the most
out of your profile on edut bio info
and if you do not yet have an account i
would like to
invite everyone to go ahead and create a
free account on a
duty bioinfo and during the course of
today's session as well as the rest of
the upcoming program you will see that
while we are asking you to create this
free account
because we will be sharing a lot of the
free resources
so while we are discussing you can go
ahead and create a free account on edu
dot t hyphen bio dot info so let me go
back
to the presentation
and i hope that you are able to utilize
the
profile resource to update your own
profile
and that is going to be really helpful
so now let me introduce you to the
program
mentors in the upcoming omics logic
program you will have
the opportunity to interact and
collaborate with an international team
of
experts specialized in the application
of data science to biological data sets
let me introduce you to the main
speakers of today's session
dr anita gansha is a senior research
fellow at noguchi memorial institute for
medical research
at the university of khanna her area of
work
is in genomics of infectious diseases
she applies data analytics to explore
pathogen genome data for signatures of
the emergence and spread
of drug resistant pathogens virulence
pathogens in response to
disease control interventions dr gansha
has
also been an active participant in our
recent omits logic programs
and is now a collaborator and mentor in
the upcoming
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
dr mohit mazumdar is our omits logic
project mentor and an
expert in big data computational
analysis
dr mazumba has a phd in computational
biology
and over 10 years of experience working
with industry and academia
elia brodsky is spine biotech co-founder
and ceo in his current role he has
extensive experience
working together with industry and
academic partners that are applying
multi-omics integration and
bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology
and clinical applications
like why binder matrix is an essential
skill for those
involved in infectious disease research
as well as health policy
how biafra matrix is used in projects
and what are some of the examples
and what are the benefits of this study
for
students clinicians and researchers that
elia also will be covering
in today's session
dr harpreet kaur is our omits logic
trainer
she guides the participants
in the hands-on sessions and with
project and data analysis during the
program her area of specialization is in
genomics and
machine learning i would now like to
invite dr
anita gansha to talk about her interest
in bioinformatics and the way
omits logic training has helped her
leverage
data analysis in our current malaria
research
dr anita over to you
thank you bibsa let me share my screen
um
there should be a uh oh okay can you see
my screen now
yeah do you have a slide
view itself right so um
good afternoon to you all
and thank you for joining us and good
morning
to those of us in the us thank you for
joining us for the first
in the series of um bioinformatics
training that
noguchi memorial institute for medical
research in collaboration with
pine biotech it's organizing
for um infectious disease
research so this afternoon
i'm going to give you just a tease i
know that it is um
after lunch people are tired and all
that so i've decided to give you a
cartoon version
of why bioinformatics for infectious
disease
public health and research my name as
was mentioned is anita ganza
and i work at the buche memorial
institute for medical research
so my goal is just to
show you how bioinformatics can be used
to
help us prevent um
us from dying from something that is
very awful maybe
covet yeah so that's basically what i'm
aiming to do this afternoon
so before i even start i want to ask
what is bioinformatics
is it for genomics analysis for
evolutionary studies is it for
biological algorithm development is it
for drug design
so basically you can see how we are all
scrambling to
find our niche on the bioinformatics
platform
now why do we need bioinformatics as a
stance
most of us what we do is to collect a
lot of data
and then we scratch the surface do some
analysis and put the rest down and hope
that one day
we'll come back to it um i think
um this is why we need bioinformatics
for our research activities
so bioinformatics is that's discipline
the scientific discipline that manages
engineering computer science chemistry
biochemistry biology
statistics to make sense of data
ultimately for improving health
and so we see that the biologist is
interested in the sequences
whether it is genomics proteomics
transcriptomics
data and then the computer scientist
is in charge of the algorithms the
statistician does the statistical
analysis
and the chemists is also involved with
the protein structures and how
all these will come together for a good
bioinformatics
pipeline now in public health we are
interested in
health protection surveillance um
prevention health assessment
health promotion and um
imagines preparedness so when there is
any outbreak we are interested in how we
can
fight this outbreak so
what are some of the questions that we
ask in public health
we take some posts from patients for
diagnosis
we want to know what the patients has
and how the patients
can be treated we study some posts for
surveillance
so what is circulating in the population
and what does
it mean for public health and then we
also take
environmental samples to know what's
circulating our water bodies
or water that we drink food and what
this means to public health
now in case there's an outbreak how do
we
investigate this outbreak so for
instance we are all
aware of the size of
infection how do we investigate such an
outbreak these are some of the questions
that
are public health importance to us so
we conduct surveillances to identify
cases people who are infected and these
surveillances
can include molecular epidemiology
genotyping of the pathogens
so surveillance is identifying the
various cases
then we can also go further with the
molecular epidemiology
to identify potentially which pathogens
are related
so we see some relations between the
identified pathogens in the surveillance
then the field epidemiologist is
interested
in tracking the transmission how the
infection is
being transmitted but
that is not enough
[Music]
these genotyping methods that we
i spoke about in the previous slide may
not necessarily tell you the order or
the direction of the
transmission and then the size of the
clusters that you attain
from the um genotyping
will depend on the type of method that
you use so the more detailed you go
the more information you get about the
pathogen you are interested in
now we need a lot of
epidemiological data to marry these two
and most of the time we do not have
sufficient
epi information to understand even the
genotypes that
we have attained now in summary these
are some of the
roadblocks that we encounter diagnostics
is very time consuming and
we end up not taking a lot of samples in
the population
to understand the actual dynamics of the
infection
now coming up with the exact phenotype
is very very slow it takes days
especially for
a diagnosis like um tb
and then the surveillance that we
currently do
are very low resolution because we are
using genotyping or
methods that are um low resolution
and then relies a lot on epidemiological
data
so the whole process is very complex
there are so many parallel steps
and reporting at various stages and so
these roadblocks
we need to surmount now how do we summon
such a roadblock
this is where we need genomics genomics
promises to help us among some
of these roadblocks as i know it's still
early days
some parts of the world have made a lot
of progress
we are trying in africa to also
apply genomics in our public health
systems
so we are all aware of how the
technology has advanced we have various
sequencing
platforms i don't even know the names of
these ones the my sig the high six and
the more
um where we think the future will be
the iron terrain um platforms
we think that at the moment we are
thinking that um we can use
um whole genome sequencing to help with
rapid diagnosis we believe that the
genomes
of these pathogens contain almost
everything that we need for diagnosis
for phenotyping and for surveillance so
genomics can be used for diagnostics
the second thing that we also believe
is that genomics or whole genome
sequencing can help us
tailor therapy
so instead of going from picking a
specimen and then doing various drug
sensitivity tests
for especially tb diagnosis and then
testing various drugs to come up with
which drugs
we think that the patients may respond
to
we want to get to a point where we can
sequence
the person's genome and then align these
sequences
and have some kind of algorithms ready
that will
link your sequence types
to the drugs that
one would need so basically
personalizing
therapy we also think that we can use
whole genome sequencing to track
outbreaks
so we're following an individual in the
population who is infected
we see how the next person is also
infected
and how it is spreading in the
population there are
some changes in the pathogen we can see
that
there is a new variant in the pathogen
however at this stage we are just
tracking
the um infection
so we can go further to use this to
manage the
outbreaks see whether the activities are
directed at the right persons and at the
right locations
but as you can see this man here is
asking
is that all no it's not finished we
forgotten about
within host genetic diversity
so this is where we start looking at
how a pathogen in an individual
is changing or branching into
the b type or the c type and basically
this is where
the statisticians will bring their
statistics
on board and then we can eventually
develop
a nice phylogenetic tree to look at
how these pathogens are related
and on a time scale
now furthermore we can also
merge a number of these phylogenetic
trees
based on social networks let's say
various and
groupings in a society and come up with
a more complex
analysis like this then we can also
marry the epidemiological data to get
the final construction of a network of
how the pathogen is interacting the
pathogens are interacting
within individuals and also with
transmission
in a population but it's all not done
we can there are also certain very minor
variants
within this um population that we can
further
mine further complex and
the kind of analysis that we can do yeah
you may think that it's all no there's
still a lot more that we can do with um
whole genome sequencing or ngs
we can use it to understand the dynamics
of infections
so basically if you sequence and
assemble your genomes
and then you build your phylogenetic
tree you can plot the prevalence
of these subclones across space
and time to understand how
and why the epidemic is happening so
for public health this is one interest
the next thing is also to use these
sequencing
data to discover completely brand new
pathogens
so for instance if you do a metagenomics
analysis of a patient with an unknown
disease you can blast
the reads against the database of known
organisms
and look at the set of rates that didn't
match to any known organism
and then try and sequence in the lab and
piece
various um um
regions together and if it is what
calling
a completely known pathogen then you do
so
now for something like um size curve 2
we are comparing this novel pathogen
with other genomes within the genus
coronavirus grouping
and to identify which regions have
changed
by comparative genomics with a known um
coronavirus and we established the new
sas code
covet 19. now we can also
use sequencing data to understand the
drivers
and evolution of within host
and population level evolution of
resistance to these pathogens
next what else we can do is to
track the date and time of a viral
infection not only viral infections
from our phylogenetic tree we can
pinpoint
the actual time of origin
of a new variant in the population
we can also use um genomics data
to do this therapeutic monitoring of
drug resistance
so you sequence an individual
or a patient and then you scan this
genome for
mutations and determine which drugs
would work for the person
if probably the person is already on a
certain drug
regimen you can change it based on the
genotypes that the individual
has got we can also use
pathogen genomics to understand the
population structure
of these pathogens you see how various
certain um
pathogens are clustered or grouped
and others are separated so we see this
substructuring within
the population to understand where which
areas or for instance which countries
have similar pathogens
and basically how the pathogens are
structured in the various
populations that we are interested in
now for drug resistance we can also use
pathogen genomics to predict resistance
there are many mutations in the genome
some
may be compensatory but some may also
lead to resistance so you can look at it
which of the reverence will predict
a resistant phenotype
we can also use it for diagnosis
[Music]
people are actually developing new
diagnostic tools
in based on the sequences that
we generate from um pathogens
and then in epidemiology we use it to
infer transmission of
genomics data it's not enough to
just sequence your genome
you need to marry it with the epic
information
of your population to understand
the transmission the dynamics of the
transmission and how
basically the pathogen is driving this
transmission now i can't stop
without talking about malaria that is my
area of interest so i'll do a few slides
on malaria
before i hand it over to ilia so for
malaria control
and elimination basically we are
targeting malaria elimination and
ultimate
eradication our goal is to come up with
new tools that will be useful for
diagnosis
for prevention and treatment and for
stopping transmission
or prevent reintroduction of parasites
in areas with zero prevalence so
as we are controlling the malaria
parasites
and the vectors and we get to
elimination what we are expecting is
very very low transmission
and when we get to the zero prevalence
um
that would be eradication but as we go
on transmission
is reducing so imagine that we will need
very innovative
ways of diagnosing the disease
in let's say one in
200 or one in a thousand people just
getting
malaria how can you pick such a low
infection
in a few people and how effectively we
can prevent and treat the disease
and also if there is a reintroduction
of the parasite in a population where
this parasite has already been
eliminated we can quickly
localize this infection and then deal
with it
now what do we have in our tool set at
the moment
we have a number of vector control
interventions such as
indoor residual spraying with
insecticides
and then long-lasting bed nets
to prevent filtered bed nets to prevent
um
transmission and then we have preventive
therapies such as
sp sulfidoxin perimeter i mean for
pregnant women
for children and then intermittent
treatment of populations
with low transmission and then we have
our diagnostic kits microscopy
rapid diagnostic testing and we have our
current
atomicine based combination therapy for
treatment
and we've established quite a strong
malaria surveillance system
we have one vaccine that is at the pilot
implementation stage so
it's going through it's the phase four
pilot
implementation it's been approved and
currently being tested
in um ghana
kenya and um malawi
yeah they're thinking about how it can
be ruled out
successfully in our
countries so these are what we have in
our two sets
but the challenge is the extensive
genetic diversity in the parasite genome
so you see how diverse the parasite can
look like
and for the malaria parasite there are
many levels
from the mosquito stage it
adapts it adapts in the mosquito through
diversity and then it moves into the
liver stage of the
individual and there again
it diversifies its genome in order to be
able to evade
the liver stage and then moves into the
paras the red blood cell
and again it has to undergo extensive
diversity
so this makes it very complex for any
malaria
and genomic studies or malaria
intervention
the idea of the parasites extensive
diversity
is just to evade the host immune system
and
pressures such as the drug and the
vaccines that
we take and unfortunately for us
the current anti-malaria therapy the
atomism-based combination therapy
is already showing signs of resistance
the parasite is resisting this and drug
and we see this in the greater mekong
region around cambodia
thailand and the rest and recently in
africa
in rwanda resistance to the acts has
also emerged
and we already have insecticide
resistance
also in the vectors the mosquitoes
and there is a deletion in the genes
that are
used in developing a rapid diagnostic
test so what are we left with
yeah so the but the good news is that
with all the advancement in technology
for malaria elimination we have a number
of tools
we are evolving from doing simple
um nucleotide or nucleic acid
amplification techniques like
pcr for genotyping molecular bar coding
we are advancing to microarray
technology
whole genome sequencing we also have
whole transcriptome
sequences and then that gene drive
using techniques like the crispr cast
gene editing then we also have
a huge genetic or genomics database
or repository that we can tap from
some of these resources i have listed
here we have the human genome
so we can look at the human genome the
parasite genome
the mosquito genome is also available we
have plasmodb
gin db the malaria gen
pf 3k genome we have the
mosquito thousand genome
ncbi genbank and vector base
these are some of the tools that have
stored a huge database
um yes you may not find enough
metadata to go with it but there is a
lot that we can explore
together with our own sequences that we
have generated
and some of the questions that we can
ask
by using whole genome sequencing or any
genotyping platform is to understand
or get some insights into the the
parasites
biology its ability to adapt
and track these parasites as they
respond to
interventions like the drugs or vaccines
or even now
the
parasite genomic data is being used
as proxy for vector control
interventions um to understand
transmission
the reason being that as the their
vectors are being shrunk by the
interventions like the indoor residual
spraying
or the
bed nets they shrink with a parasite
population and so these parasites
remaining after these interventions have
become proxy for
estimating transmission after vector
control interventions
we can also look at genetic mapping by
linkage or
genome-wide association studies
genome-wide association studies have
been used to look at
regions of the genome that are under
strong
recent selection and these have been
seen
for candidates for um
drug resistant candidates new graduates
and candidates have been
developed or detected using genome-wide
scans for these signature softwares and
selection
and then they can also be manipulated to
look for
causal variants so if you're interested
in phenotypes like
severe malaria are there any causal
variants to
severe malaria we can also map
the genome or transcriptome
to look at differential expression
patterns
throughout the various life cycles of
the
the stages of the life cycle to enable
us identify
new drug and vaccine targets and this is
an
area that not much has been
done we also need preemptive
surveillance of the african parasite
population for genetic markers
of emergence of drug resistance because
um
apart from just tracking
the genotypes that have been the
genes or variants or mutations that have
been
associated with or have been identified
as functional for
act resistance there are
signs that we may have different
mutations apart from what has been
established
in the greater mekong region so it's
important to look for
what is lincoln
drug resistance in the greater mekong
region i'm talking about the k-13 gene
here
there are new variants in the k-13 that
may
explain or give us a different pattern
for our resistance
and of course we know that the ketene
gene alone is
not the gene responsible may not be the
only gene responsible for atomic
resistance so
there is a need to look for other
markers of um
drug resistance and then we need new
tools to develop
drugs vaccines insecticides and
diagnostic tools as i mentioned
there are deletions in the
genes used for the um rapid diagnostic
test
and these will require some insulin co
designs
but we also have to think about
validating whatever
signals we pick from the genomes or
transcriptome
or proteome with laboratory validations
so the long story
is summarized here i'm saying that you
should take home
the fact that if you have a clinical
diagnosis of an
infectious disease you can look at the
epidemiology
or laboratory procedures that is what we
do
we do um disease population surveillance
disease outbreak investigations we take
samples and isolate
dna and we do traditional identification
look for drug resistance but we can
go further by using sequencing and
bioinformatic tools to
get more insight in the sequences that
we generate
so we do our pcr amplification we
assemble our sequence and then
we do our pathogen identification
we map it onto reference genomes you do
your comparative
genomics and phylogenetic analysis
clinical genotyping
but with this huge database
huge sequence database we will get more
insights that will lead to
discovery of new drug targets new
vaccines
understand the biology behind our
pathogens
and more insights
into the emergence of resistance or how
resistance the mechanism underlining
resistance
and a huge area of immune responses that
i'm not even touching
and ultimately this will inform public
health for
disease control and prevention and then
clinical medicine
for our well-being so i thank you for
your time and i'll hand over to
elia to continue with the presentations
thank you
thank you anita if you could hold for
just one second there's a few
questions that people want to know so
abraham paul is asking thank you for
this presentation dr anita please what
is your group doing to improve the
malaria diagnosis
are you working on alternative diagnosis
maybe cheaper rapid or more sensitive
techniques for malaria
what is your malaria diagnostic focus in
your group thank you
thank you very much abraham well
i personally am not currently working on
diagnostic tools but at noguchi
dr linda amwa she experienced the
[Music]
national malaria control programs and
surveillance of
those hrp2
and three deletions in ghana and
i know that ultimately she will come up
with
new diagnostic tools she is also
exploring the genome so
that group is handling diagnosis but
definitely
there is some work in exploring the
genome having seen that the
hrp2 gene or three gene
there are some deletions and therefore
we are not picking them
and they are not properly diagnosed in
malaria
and another question is what is the
status of plasmodium population
structure
in ghana from francis
so the plasmodium population is
extensively diverse in
ghana um we don't
have a complete ghana plus medium
population structure data but we have
looked at population structure in
various
regions in the country
we have three major ecological zones so
for the middle belt for the coastal belt
and then the northern belt
we have looked at the population
structure
yes in the northern zone
there are a few um clusters but
ultimately it is
very very heterogeneous
so we think that the interventions
are slowly breaking down the
structure and there's a lot of gene flow
across
all the sites in ghana
this is explaining very extensive
diversity and heterogeneous population
structure we see
thank you and the last question i
believe what is the pattern between
villages and cities and
and i will just mention for the rest of
the questions
uh we will continue to speak about
malaria so
after this last question from francis
we'll come back to questions
in a few slides after this
so what is the pattern
from village to cities well
so these are the things that we have to
track unfortunately we are
not really tracking but um
we expect a pattern
because of a lot of migration we expect
to see a pattern
and again as i said the parasite
population is very very
diverse unless we get a specific
marker that we can use to track this
particular pattern
um we know that people are moving
migration is very
rife in ghana but the population is so
diverse and um
even though we have not specifically
looked at
patterns from village to cities
yeah okay thank you very much dr
ganza and we'll come back to these uh
important and interesting questions in
just a few more minutes so um thank you
again for sharing this important
information i think it was very
fascinating to hear all of this and i
want to
kind of turn your attention now to some
more
practical overview of this upcoming
training that will start with a focus on
how
bioinformatics can be leveraged for
infectious disease research
and specifically in the context of
today's webinar how can bioinformatics
help us
analyze host vector pathogen interaction
so before i continue i want to kind of
connect some of the things that were set
up until now
so when we joined the first part was an
introduction to omixlogic which is a
program
that is designed to facilitate
bioinformatics training and we also
heard about dr anita gansa
about how bioinformatics could be
applied in so many different ways
and i think what's important for anyone
who is starting to utilize
bioinformatics
is to have a complete roadmap
for bioinformatics and so what i will
try to do
in my portion of this presentation is to
help connect some of these
important and significant topics in
infectious disease research
with specific practical hands-on
tools that anyone can use and i want to
try and
make it as broad as possible to involve
people
that maybe have zero background in
bioinformatics
as well as people that might already
have some experience in bioinformatics
but would like to
enrich their skills and make the most
out of
this upcoming opportunity for training
so
a complete road for bioinformatics in my
opinion
has to do with finding data sets that
might be able to be used for answering
the types of questions that we've
discussed
some practical skills on exploring and
visualizing these data sets to guide our
hypothesis
development to understand research
methods that are being used in
cutting-edge research publications so
that
we can implement similar methods to
analysis of our own
or similar data sets and gaining
insights and understanding that are
validated
and we are confident in so really that
is the objective
and in today's webinar what we wanted to
talk about
is a little bit how bioinformatics could
be
leveraged in very practical ways and
then to talk about some examples that we
will cover
in the upcoming program for those that
might be interested in some of these
aspects
so as you know the major difference
between infectious diseases
and non-infectious diseases is that
infectious diseases in general
are caused by pathogens and they spread
and so they're also called
communicable diseases but as anita
already
pointed out there are so many factors
involved
and one of the primary factors beyond
the study of the pathogen itself
is how does that pathogen cause disease
or what
is the process of pathogenesis how do
these pathogens
replicate how do they cause different
toxins to be released and harm
the host and ultimately how can we study
the impacts of this disease progression
at different stages
and caused by different pathogens
another
important part of that is obviously how
can
the immune system be leveraged to
stop prevent and protect people
from these kinds of pathogens and so in
the context of
vaccine design uh what dr anita already
mentioned and we have a number of
important interventions that have been
designed
maybe over a hundred years ago already
that have shown to reduce
the rates of infection and protect the
larger
portion of the population from such
infections and these are not
just the vaccines in fact some of the
most basic things
like uh use of chlorine in water
or for example separation
from different types of species have
caused an immense reduction
in the rates of infection and then the
vaccines
have also revolutionized the way that
people have dealt with
infections over the past decade or over
the past uh
sorry 100 years and so today when we're
looking at
how we arrived at a place when we are
again
dealing with a pandemic that is
surpassing
the rates of death from other
non-communicable diseases
is something that requires us to rethink
this strategy of prevention and
antiviral
intervention or anti-pathogen
intervention measures
so when we think today where we are in
our ability to understand how pathogens
overcome the traditional methods how
new pathogens are causing important
dangerous outbreaks like we see in
kovid19
and how we all know that covet 19 is
just
one of coronaviruses that have been
around and have been causing
mild mild disease in the past
so how can similar changes in pathogens
can ultimately cause another outbreak
and how can we be prevent
prepared for that and my proposal here
is to say that
as researchers all of us play a major
role
in that preparedness and a lot of what
dr agansa already mentioned including
the understanding of the basic
mechanisms of replication transmission
and pathogenesis our understanding of
how
the virus causes disease in the host
response
and our ability to leverage such data
in a rapid way to quickly identify
insights that could be practically
translated
to active measures we are talking about
essentially putting all of this data in
context
so what's really amazing is the speed
at which such data has been gaining
or accelerating over the past maybe
decade or two in fact today
we live in an era of exponential growth
of structural data genomic data
transcriptomic data
all kinds of high throughput data that
ultimately together
indicate how hosts interact with
pathogens
and how we can leverage the immune
responses and the natural
defenses of different organisms to
really understand disease
and be much more informed about the
opportunities to be effective at
intervention and so what we want to do
in this training program that we're
going to describe
in just a few more minutes about how
this program is going to be organized
delivered
and how all of you can register we would
like to
focus on a few different types of
infectious disease
data sets and that includes viral
genomics and
evolution immune response and biomarkers
and the microbiome and infection
and in fact if you look at this kind of
data you will see
that a lot of such data really
contextualizes
what we already know so we see that from
the time that the human genome has been
sequenced
now there has been a parallel growth
in our understanding of the human genome
as well as
in the genomes of different viruses that
have been studied in the context of the
microbiome
and in the context of what's called
divine rome which is
probably even more complex than the
metagenome
and so when we look at the changes in
the way that sequencing data is
generated
when we look at the ways that different
types of data
can categorize different forms of life
or even how we can study different forms
of infection that are caused by maybe
non-living things like
viruses and try to place them in the
categories that we have to deal with
in the tree of life so the key
technology to all of these
as was already mentioned is next
generation sequencing
and one important part to start
leveraging
next generation sequencing effectively
is
a workflow to help transform next
generation sequencing
into structured data that could be
readily analyzed
by anyone and so one of the things that
we would like to introduce you today
is a platform that can help you
gain the most out of available data sets
that you might have generated in the lab
or that are publicly available so that
you can
generate hypotheses from publicly
available data sets
or be more effective at extracting
greater
insights and more detailed and precise
insights
from the data that you generate so
what's out there
in terms of publicly available next
generation sequencing data
so first of all we can see that in the
past
two decades there has been an
exponential growth
of genomic data about pathogens
in different public repositories and
that
includes different types of repositories
like the ncbi and so you've probably
heard of the recent
kind of update to ncbi virus where there
are over 13 000
genomes and if we're talking about
malaria
or other kinds of non-viral diseases
not ncbi virus but ncbi itself has also
huge collections of these genomes but
they're also specialized repositories
for
specific diseases not only that today
as we all know we hear about genomic
data
all the time and so even the greater
population not researchers and not
students of these topics
are now familiar with the relevance of
identification of specific variants
the impact of variance on transmission
and pathogenesis
and how critical this data is to
our ability to understand and track
these infectious diseases
now beyond that we also have the host
data so for example
on the gene expression omnibus on the
ncbi repository that is dedicated to
gene expression studies
there are over 80 000 publicly available
data sets
that speak about drug response that show
us how pathogenesis happens and allow us
to interrogate
how different types of genomic
variations from the host
can have a difference on the way that
disease is manifested in different hosts
and how it is carried by different
vectors and
more importantly there are novel
techniques that are emerging
like metagenomic and viral sequences or
even real-time sequences of
outbreaks that allow us to understand
the disease
and contextualize it with what's
happening
around that for example how that relates
to the different
measures that the health ministry can
implement and how that has to do with
different types of interventions so i
think that we're really
living in an era of big data
that is defined by the different types
of data
that is defined by also different types
of applications of data so it's
extremely significant
that we all have the ability and the
tools
to effectively manage analyze and
interpret such data efficiently
and so one important thing about this is
that not only has the data become
more and more affordable as a result of
the diversification of the different
types of data generation
we can see also a variety of different
formats
and so before i continue our interest in
this webinar is to present you with the
upcoming program and tell you some of
the topics that we will cover
but it is also to get to know you and so
before i continue
i obviously do not know many of you or
the majority of you
and so i would like to propose a few
questions so that we can
ask and get the information about the
current participants
so the first question that i have is
what is your current level of education
so if you could please look at these
questions and put the response
by putting for example 1b for
undergraduate degree
or 1d for postgraduate so the first
question
is what is your current level of
education 1a
high school or no degree 1b
undergraduate degree or
bachelor's 1c graduate degree or
master's
and d post graduate phd and that also
is for those that are
researchers and faculty
okay thank you very much and by the way
we will use this information
uh to further tailor our uh webinars
and sessions in the future to provide
you with more
um information relevant to you okay
excellent thank you so i see a lot of
one b's
and one d's all right and one c is also
someone see okay
great excellent thank you very much um
and my second question is
you know this webinar is introducing you
to an upcoming training program
that is hosted by the naguchi memorial
institute
for biomedical research and so we are
interested to know how the information
that you've seen
so far could be interesting for you
so the questions for the second question
is what do you or what yes what do you
expect from this
program 2a learn about bioinformatics
2b get familiarized with infectious
diseases
2c overview of bioinformatics and
biology
2d apply bioinformatics to a research
project so
what would you say characterizes your
personal interest
the most okay
excellent so a lot of 2ds which is
applying bioinformatics
to a research project and i assume that
is because most of you are already
studying
infectious diseases and hopefully out of
this session you would get a little bit
more information of
how bioinformatics could be applied to
your research
and also what are the specifics not just
broad topics like we've discussed up
until now
but what are the specific practical
skills that you can gain from here
okay so i have another two questions so
thank you again for all of your answers
here
number one what is your primary interest
in terms of your research
because many of you answered that you're
interested in research so 3a
parasites like malaria for example 3b
viral infection
like covet 3c bacterial infection like
tuberculosis
3d all of the above or any infectious
disease so you're really disease
agnostic
okay so here are some so please yes make
sure you answer with the right
three okay 3d 3c okay so
a lot of a variety of different
interests thank you
and the last question for today's
session
is again what is your primary interest
in terms of what are you interested to
apply bioinformatics to
and sorry this should be for 4a
pathogen 4b host response
4c vector transmission and 4d host
pathogen vector interaction
okay i'll just give here a minute for
anyone
to finish answering these questions
all right excellent thank you very much
for your answers
we are going to analyze your answers to
really inform
our next series of webinars and uh
the training sessions that we will have
in the program
let me briefly introduce you to some
resources
that we will leverage throughout this
program
so as anita already or sorry as
beeps already mentioned in the very
beginning
of this webinar we have a training
portal
that all of you are invited to register
in and all of you are invited to
start exploring even creating a free
account
because in the context of this upcoming
training program
we will leverage a variety of resources
related
to this portal so here once you have
registered
you will see a variety of courses that
are designed around specific
types of omics data that go from
the very basics all the way to the more
advanced
bioinformatics methodology and all of
these resources
could be used asynchronously to study on
your own
however for many people having
asynchronous resources like coursera edx
or the t bioinfo platform
is not really enough and so what we will
try to do
in this program is guide the
participants
from where you currently are with or
without any bioinformatics background
to understand the specific details
of bioinformatics so that you can be
independent
in your research to ask questions of
data
and get results or answers to your
questions
so in the context of this program this
is one important resource that you will
have access to and you can start looking
over
the courses here or some of the
collections of courses
and projects that you will find that
take
a specific data set and explain
what that data set could be used in the
context
of a research question now let's talk
about
some specifics so specifically when we
talk about bioinformatics
the journey of a bioinformatician starts
with finding a data set and so when we
speak about genomic data
there are major two types of data that
provide this
with genomic information about the
pathogen
we can look at fast u files that provide
us
with an in-depth look of what's in our
sequencing data
or we can deal with faster files that
can describe
genomic variation that could later on be
interpreted
so one of the applications of these is
to
understand the significance of mutations
in terms of codon mapping
and the impact of a particular mutation
on
the amino acid and even on the structure
of a protein
as you probably are all familiar
familiar with
this could be done by leveraging
multiple sequence alignment
at the nucleotide or amino acid level
and understand the relationship between
sequences
using what's called phylogenetic tree
reconstruction so one of the
important parts of what we will go
through in this program
is take these different examples that we
just looked at
ebola virus tuberculosis malaria and
analyze those genomic sequences both as
consensus sequences in faster files but
also
in raw next-generation sequencing data
so that we can
look at the in-depth mutation analysis
that reveal haplotypes and different
populations
of host pathogens and how they interact
so for example
one of the things that we will do is we
will look at geospatial analysis where
we can link specific sequences
to their location and the time where
they have been
found another important use
for such data is to find single
nucleotide polymorphisms
and in the context of big data
it is a challenge because we will look
at the
impact of coverage on our ability to
detect
low frequency mutations and
differentiate between low and high
frequency mutations
to study populations of pathogens but
also the emergence
of dominant strains and how we can
characterize those
in large groups of samples for example
when we talk about cobit 19
when the first sequence was put together
was assembled
that looked like this you have a lot of
different reads
those reads have been mapped on some
reference and a consensus sequence
has been provided but when we talk about
analysis of such data there are many
indicators that we can extract from such
data
that will allow us to ask very different
questions about
how this consensus sequence could be
compared to
other consensus sequences or how can the
raw fastq data can reveal
different types of snips different types
of combinations of snips
and different types of information about
their relationships
now in the context of such practical
analysis
we will use our t value for platform
for big data so let me show you what
that looks like
so again this is the educational portal
edu dot
t dash bio dot info now we can go
to server dot t dash bio
dot info so server t bio
info and so uh beeps if you could please
post the
link and also a demo account and so i
want to introduce this platform
in the context of an efficient tool
that you can leverage in your omics data
research
so here we will talk about how you can
uh take fast q files or fasta files
uh and by the way thank you beeps for
posting the link
and the username and password anyone can
log in with this username and password
just to kind of explore some demo
examples of what we will go through and
here
anyone even without knowledge of
bioinformatics
and without access to high throughput
computing resources with large ram
and large storage can analyze
publicly available data sets as well as
private data sets that you have
generated in your lab
so here you'll find many different
sections for next generation sequencing
data analysis
for mass spec structural biology
as well as data integration and modeling
and especially
a section that was designed around
virology studies
so here you can see a number of
different examples
for example how you can build a
phylogenetic tree
and this could be done using fast q
files
or assemble genomes in fasta files
we will also look at how to analyze
transcriptomic data so for example how
we can build
a whole pipeline to study
patterns in our next generation
sequencing data
for transcriptomic data analysis and
this is a really
simple tool that will
eliminate the complexity of
bioinformatics analysis
to produce interesting results that you
can gain
insights from without any coding
and without having to have your own
high throughput computing resources so
here for example we are looking at
an example of mapping a sample
to a reference genome to find alignment
of reads to the reference genome and
even look
at how we can find variants in the
sequence
or understand what those reads represent
so these kinds of examples in the
context of
again viral infection bacterial
infection
and parasite infection we will look at
these kinds of studies
as well as the host response so
what are the different sections that we
will cover we'll cover
phylogenetic analysis gene expression
analysis
alignment with multiple sequence
alignment or alignment of reads to
reveal snips
variant calling and even structural
biology how we can map those variants
onto structures of proteins understand
the impact
of mutations on the function of
a particular protein so as i mentioned
this platform will help you build the
logic of analysis
combining multiple scripts into what's
called bioinformatics pipelines
understand the different inputs and
outputs in terms of the logic or the
sequence of how they are connected
together
understanding each method that are
explained
as you build your pipeline different
types of
inputs and outputs for analysis
including
this example of transcriptomic data
analysis
you will see how such a guided process
with the help of our trainers will help
you establish
a logic behind these workflows and make
reproducible research and importantly
you will find access to a variety of
different sections
that are all built around a similar
interface
so using this platform and a number of
other resources we will talk about
sequence variation evolutionary
relationships
relationships between function and
structure
and host response either as a vector
or as an host and so that way you can
start contextualizing
some of these questions that we
discussed in this webinar
in the context of available data sets
that we will also introduce you to
and in the context of how to transform
your questions
into a specific um
transcript in a specific analysis
approach so to conclude
i wanted to open up now a
question a slide
so if you had any questions about this
program you can post that here
you can also post questions about some
of the topics that we discussed related
to analysis
and to help guide us in this discussion
i also have here a number of questions
that you can
think about so that we can have an
effective discussion so the first one
is which university or department you
are currently in
then how often do you deal with next
generation sequencing data in your lab
or in your research or in your studies
and typically is it generated by you or
have you or
do you currently leverage publicly
available data sets or maybe both
three what is your current uh training
experience with bioinformatics
sorry this should be three and this
should be
um and how needed is
additional training in bioinformatics
for you or for your department so
these are some questions uh to help
guide this discussion
um you can definitely put your
answers into the chat box and
if you are interested in kind of uh
unmuting yourself and
uh asking the question or answering one
of these questions
uh publicly please feel free to do that
as well
okay so i see that rhodes university
um some james is answering that he's an
intern at the naguchi immunology
department
manav rajna dental college
okay and i'm assuming that the majority
here are from
the uh naguchi um uni
okay so i'm not so
familiar with the abbreviations like
k-n-u-s-t
and k-c-c-r
all right thank you humboldt university
phd student
university of health and allied sciences
excellent thank you very much so we hope
that these
free sessions like today will be of
interest and beneficial to you to not
only learn about bioinformatics but also
gain some practical exposure to
bioinformatics methods of analysis
we have included a variety of different
free resources that most of you will
have
access to but also in just a few moments
uh many of you will be introduced to our
upcoming training program which is a
paid program
um and some of those paid programs will
also include some free webinars so we'll
go over that schedule
in just a few minutes so as you stay
you'll see
more information on that
okay sweden ghana medical center
biochemical engineering
indian institute of technology bhu
undergraduate and junior
okay thank you um victor sang has not
yet gained
access to next generation sequencing
data
all right thank you very much
suez canal university egypt okay thank
you dr venna
a boyle care
okay thank you phd student biotechnology
from
ben gurion university in israel all
right great to see you here abraham
nmimr university of ghana thank you dido
okay um lewis is saying that he's aware
of the data sets available and hope to
use them
and uh victor is saying that he has
basic experience on bioinformatics
beginner
university of the western cape south
africa all right
excellent so again thank you all for
your answers
we will just keep this for one more
minute so please answer some of your
questions
and again we will also be interacting
with you so as you're going
through um these questions uh
i also want to mention that one of the
first courses that we invite you to
complete
in the context of bioinformatics
training
is a free introduction to bioinformatics
asynchronous course
that is on the edu.t bioinfo website
and on this website you will find that
the first
lesson is actually a survey and so we're
really looking forward
to learning more about you about your
background
about your interests hoping that we can
leverage the
resources that we already have to help
you
get more hands-on experience
okay so thank you again all of you for
the
answers i think that an important part
of what we have discussed today is not
only
the training and the lessons and the
education but i think that in many cases
we are interested in taking this further
and applying bioinformatics tools to a
particular
project and so to speak about projects
what projects are and how such training
is going to help you develop
a project of your own i am going to
pass the presentation over to dr mihit
mizunder
who is our project coordinator
and business development person
so uh muhit i'll pass it on to you
thank you ilya and thank you
to the other presenters uh anita and
deepisha
let me share my screen
okay hello everyone uh a very good
evening to all the participants
uh my name is mohit mazumdar and in my
current role i'm collaboratively working
with universities and research
institutes
and labs to provide support for
bioinformatics research and training i'm
really excited excited to be
to be a part of this omix logic and
pictures disease research program
as a project mentor and to be able to
work on translational research
with a diverse group of students faculty
with diverse expertise so my phd was
focused
on using bioinformatics and data science
techniques to predict and identify
biological patterns
and with this experience of working on
several published research projects
as a project mentor i will i will help
the program participants
with analysis steps and understanding
the sequence data and the pattern within
and further use structural biology
tools and computational modeling of
biological systems to
develop a deeper understanding of the
system biology
so uh as you know and as we have been
discussing so far
bioinformatics and application of ngs
and clinical data
are increasingly contributing in both
academia
and pharmaceutical industry research and
development
and this is quite evident from the rapid
data growth generation that is happening
right now so our understanding of
infectious disease
caused by bacterial pathogens such as
mycobacterium tuberculosis
and parasites such as plasmodium
falciparum
as well as viruses such as ebola and
covid19
so today i will introduce you to
several examples of how this
example of how this can be done
successfully by researchers
uh um who are studying viral infections
such as
ebola virus outbreak in west africa
covid 19 pandemic as well as microbial
pathogen
that we discussed tuberculosis and the
single cell parasites
which is malaria so we will briefly
touch on
viral genomics and evolution gene
expression patterns
uh transcriptomics that was discussed
detection
of significant genomic variants as well
as
look into the microbiome and the viral
communities in a host
that will help us to you know find those
important associations
with disease susceptibility and those
outcomes
so this uh kind of investigation is
going to be really fascinating because
we will be kind of uh focused on as
and this has been discussed about the
disease outbreaks and
pathogenesis host pathogen genomic
variations
and then host immune invasion mechanisms
so these are really exciting and you
know
very important topics that we will be
talking about including the
identification of biomarkers
or vaccine targets so in the context
of this training program many of the
projects
we have been developing and will be used
as an example
so mutation mutation profiling of ebola
virus outbreak
as i mentioned and then origin of and
pathogenesis of noble coronavirus
as well as noble techniques on low
frequency mutation studies in including
cersei sequencing in polio virus
so uh as you see that we have uh
we will be using amino acid and three
dimensional structure and
ngs data to be able to understand the
research question that has been posed
so this research program
that we will be doing and that we have
been discussing and we will be
discussing
uh in the next few slides will include
scheduled and structured training
and the purpose of this doing this is to
lea
this training should lead to a research
outcome
so in this program we will combine
online sessions
guided study material um so we will have
online sessions like the one that we are
having right now
and then we have uh these uh courses and
hands-on guide
and tutorials so we will use those
and then we will be using practical
assignments for this immersive
experience that has been proven
effective in our well-respected
omics logic programs so in order to make
the most of this training
we will be helping and guiding you
throughout this training
so with this uh let me invite our omics
logic trainer dr harpreet cott
so dr harpreet kaur is one of the
trainers that will help
facilitate many of the sessions and her
areas of specialization
is in ngs data genomics transcriptomics
and application of machine learning so
with this i will give it to over to you
dr
dr core thank you dr mohit
let me share my screen
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics
uh during my doctoral research my focus
is on biomarker discovery
for the diagnosis and the prognosis of
the liver cancer
so what inspired me to take liver cancer
as my doctoral research topic is the
high mortality rate of this malignancy
and lack of the precise my biomarker
that that helped to diagnose liver
cancer
at an early stage so liver cancer
is considered as sixth major cancer in
terms of
incidence and force in terms of
mortality
so then what are the major issues that
are associated with the liver cancer
include
is inaccurate diagnosis and then its
late diagnosis specifically in the
latest days
and then another reason that results for
the poor prognosis of the patients
is the tumor reoccurrence so keeping
these concern in mind we have
uh try to address these issues using
various bioinformatics approaches so in
the first part we have
extracted the nearly 4000 sample from
the public repository that are
associated with the hepatocellular
carcinoma
and by employing different
bioinformatics techniques
we have identified three gene based
biomarker
that can include clac 1b fcn3 and prc1
in the next part we focused on the
second
primary malignancy of the liver cancer
that is chlangiocarcinoma
for this purpose we have retrieved
nearly
900 samples from the one of major public
repository that is jio
and then we have lucidated uh three
ccs pacific signature which include lam
c2 itc and c2 uh
employing various machine learning
techniques
like random forest logistic regression
svm etc
and in next part to identify liver
cancer at an early stage
we have explored transcriptomics as well
as the methylation data
of the three nearly 350 scc patients
and then employing various statistical
and bioinformatics techniques that
include random forest
than various feature selection technique
eventually we have identified
51 signature that include 30 rna
transcript and
21 methylation cpg sites
that can predict liver cancer at an
early stage
so keeping overall inconclusion from
this my
doctor research eventually we have
identified three gene based biomarker to
predict
scc and then to predict cca
and then we have identify 51 signature
to predict liver cancer at an early
stage
so in my current role
i am omixlogic bioinformatics trainer
so with continuation to my research here
we are designing
different research projects
based on the public data sets so for
example in the first project is
already dr mohit has shown you
that is based on the uh reason and the
pathogenesis of
noble coronavirus that is sars scope 2.
so in this process we will explore
explore the ngs data to understand its
origin
and how much it related with already
existing human coronavirus
strains and here in this project further
we
will try to understand what are
important components of the viruses
through which they enter into the human
cell
subsequently we also look into
how it is different from other
coronavare strains
in terms of mutations so in the later
part of this project
we also try to identify important
signature
that can significantly different under
different
therapeutic treatment and untreated
conditions
besides we have also developed a project
on another pandemic that is evola
so in this project we used next
generation sequencing data
to monitor the pandemic here we employed
various bioinformatics approaches to
analyze genomic sequences identify
particular viruses in the patient sample
through the identification of
significant
variance determine the relationship
between viruses
and identify shared origin of viral
genomes
and eventually we will try to try to
understand
to identify a connection between genomic
variation
and this is phenotypes
so during this upcoming program
uh many of you can explore these
projects
that are specifically based on the
infectious disease
and i'm looking forward to become your
project mentor
uh during this program now i would like
to invite pizza
to talk about registration process
so over to your website thank you so
much dr harpreet
i'll be quickly sharing my screen over
here
and let me take you through the next
steps as we know that a lot of you have
questions about how to register for the
program
what is the schedule so we will be going
over them very quickly in this upcoming
three-month
training program we will discuss in
depth about bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
go over an in-depth training in genomics
transcriptomics as well as have
do a research project that already dr
mohit
and dr harpreet has been showing
we have designed this program to
introduce
the data resources and tools that you
can use to apply
bi-infomatrix to publicly available data
on
infectious diseases in this program we
will
understand viral diversity and its role
in
epidemic infectious diseases that keep
re-emerging
including zoonotic transmission
transmission between humans
and the process of viral and bacterial
disease
development we'll learn about
bioinformatics
analysis approaches to study viral
genome
and understand the relationships between
viral strains haplotypes
find differences in sequence data and
see the implications
for drug and vaccine design you will
gain
hands-on experience by analyzing curated
data sets from public domain collections
guided by experts with bioinformatic
experience
and knowledge about virology here
is an example of a pro project that
dr gansha was part of along with
her collaborator dr emika where they
used
transcriptomic analysis
so this project again is available uh
on our youtube channel and i will be
sharing the link
with everyone after this program if
you're already registered for the
program
and have registered for this webinar you
will receive an email with the details
to all of these projects and learn more
about how this entire process works out
now moving on uh so if you are
already a member of uh noguchi
memorial then you have to reach out to
dr
anita and you will also receive an email
for us regarding the rest of the
registration process for those of you
who are not part of nogochi and are
still
interested in attending this three-month
program
so this is not a one-month program this
is a three-month program
and we will be dealing with all of these
topics in greater details
and here you can see the breakdown of
the different pricing
on a screen so i will just keep it on
for a few more minutes
and there are also scholarships
available
for participants who are not able to
afford the program prices
so if a participant indicates a high
level of motivation
and also provides us with a rationally
to seriously consider
this request our team will reach out to
you
and you will have to note down your
references
and together we will reach out to you
talk to your references and see
whether you are fit for the scholarship
program
and then upon approval you will receive
scholarship to the program and the
scholarships we offer
are designed to help motivated talented
and promising students to benefit from
special training and research
opportunities the criteria for approval
includes a reasonable need indication of
extra
effort that the participant is willing
to put into the program
and time commitment needed to go beyond
the regular training
so to be able uh to
get access to the whole program a
participant who
is under a scholarship would need to
keep a record of the topics covered in
each of the sessions
in what we call a virtual lab journal
and you would be required to give us a
review of each of the sessions that you
are going through
make that extra effort so that we know
that uh you are taking this seriously
and we will also be sharing with you
what this scholarship
looks like and
now this is the first course that i had
uh spoken about earlier elia had also
mentioned which is the introduction to
bioinformatics
so if you have not yet taken this course
you can go to edu.t health and
buyer.info and under courses you will
find this free course
and this free course also comes with a
certificate
so you can get started with it right
away if you have not yet done
any of the courses and you can see that
there are a lot of reviews
by other participants have taken this
course
before you
and all of the activity that you do in
the course of this program
is being tracked to help you understand
your progress and evaluate your effort
at the end of the program
uh to issue and for you to get a
certificate and for us to issue that
certificate to you
we found that the most successful
participants are able to learn new
methods
develop an independent project in the
course of
these almonds logic program now let me
take you
to the website and show you how the
registration process
works so that it is clear uh
for all of you okay i'm going to be
posting the link
directly to introduction to
bioinfomatrix right now
in the chat box so for this program
many of you have already signed up and
we have your details so we will reach
out to you regarding the next step so
please
look out for emails from marketing at
pine dot bio
where i would be sharing with you
details about the program
any free resources details about
upcoming
free sessions as well so some of these
details
may be useful to you there would be
emails which may not be
useful for you because they may relate
to any other topic that you may not be
interested in so we keep on sharing all
of these resources from
time to time so you can choose to attend
a session or not attend a session so
moving on how to register for the
program
if you have not yet registered for the
program and are interested in attending
this
three three-month program please fill
out the form
at the bottom of this page so you
see there is a pre-registration form
right here
and once you fill out that
pre-registration form you will receive
details about the program
and especially if you are someone who is
again
not from noguchi then the next step that
you have to do
is go to this page this is the
infectious disease
uh checkout page so
i'm posting the link again here
sorry about this and just go back
okay i got the link so in this page
uh you will find that the program starts
with a hands-on workshop on january 29th
and it goes on till march 8th
where we will have a group project so
this is a program
which starts with very basic
understanding and builds up
with the help of asynchronous courses
live sessions like we are doing today
where you
can directly interact with a mentor ask
your questions
get them answered in a session have your
doubts cleared as well as do
hands-on analysis with the tbi
for platform or any of our other
platforms as well as
other tools using other tools like r and
python
along with your mentor so this is all
going to be
part of this three month training
program
so please register yourself by getting
started here
you will have all of these different
options
the first step if you have not yet
registered again is to go and
pre-register yourself here
and then check out using any of these
links for those in need of a scholarship
we have another page where you can
actually
talk about your scholarship
okay i'll post the link again i'm sorry
about this
yeah so the scholarship link is now in
the chat box
so if you are in need of a scholarship
please fill out the form at the bottom
of this page
and please make sure that you will have
to upload your cv
and also mention mention your references
and we would like to have a meeting with
you
as well as your reference to understand
where you are coming from and your
actual need
to get the scholarship and attend this
program
so it may be a long drawn-out process so
if you want to get started please start
applying for the program right now
and once you are enrolled in the program
you will get
access to different resources like the
course that you see here
so once you do each of these courses
each course
carries a certificate on their own
as well as there would be a program
certificate right
at the end of the program okay so if you
have any questions again regarding the
resources
please feel free to reach out to me
marketing at pine.bio
for any questions regarding access to
the program
resources uh courses projects anything
and i would be happy to answer all of
these questions for you
if you are in norwich you can reach out
to dr anita
and dr bright ado and they will be able
to help you with the next steps of the
program
and moving on once you finish the
courses you are doing the online
sessions during this
three month period you will also come
across a lot of these projects which
would be available to you
and some of which uh dr harpreet has
already shown you
like the kovid 19 project the ebola
project and you would be able to take
advantage of these projects and have
that hands-on experience
on how to work on your own project and
complete an own project as well as
conceive your own project and complete
it like
dr anita was talking about the malaria
project as well as her project with
uh dr chukwuka so you would be able to
do an independent research project
in the next three months so we are
starting
on january 29th we do not have a lot of
days so if you are looking forward to
register
kindly go ahead and register for the
program and now we are open to taking in
questions
uh so if you have any question uh please
post them down in the chat box or if you
want to unmute yourself and ask any
question
we are ready to take in any questions
from your end
so please feel free to ask us your
questions
and you can also continue to forward us
your questions to marketing and pilot
bio
and i would like to again invite you to
take a look at
our social media pages so
please go ahead and join our groups
as well as our group in linkedin
and uh dr anita do you want to add
anything right now
for the participants before we conclude
today's session
um thank you biph um i think that the
participants as has been said if you are
interested you can register
but those are noguchi some
are being fully supported
and they know themselves and the others
would have to register and then
you can get more information from dr
bright edu
of the immunology department as well so
you can reach out to dr edu
dr anita can i share your email as well
in the chat box
in case someone wants to reach out and
you can also
yes please yeah okay so i will also post
dr
uh gansha's link yeah yeah banshika you
can go ahead and ask questions
and for francis yes we do have an
intensive internship at buying bio for
three months
or six months period so francis if you
can
share your email id i can reach out to
you you can send it to me
in the chat box and still i would like
to
take everyone one more time and show
so here is how you can register
for the program which is the research
fellowship program which we have
and as part of the research fellowship
program what we do
is go through projects like you are
seeing
right now and we have been taking some
examples so
if you go through this link again you
will see
uh the project examples
from our previous participants
who have been part of programs like this
so they come from
backgrounds like neuroscience they come
from backgrounds like
oncology biology and many more
so you'll be able to see all of that
project example here
developed as part of this research
fellowship program
and pradhu mesh the recording uh so the
video is already live
in youtube and it does not get deleted
so technically the recording is
available
so as you see these are some of the
projects that were developed as part of
the program
and you can go through this link and
let us know if you're interested in
doing the research project
however the training itself the
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
itself is a long two month uh
program which comes with first training
and then
the opportunity for you to develop your
own project related to infectious
disease research
in case you're interested in researching
on any other topic which is not related
to infectious diseases
definitely you can go for the research
fellowship program
are there any questions that you would
like us to answer
thank you so much francis i will be
reaching out to you
thank you for sharing your email id
so if you do not have any more questions
i would like to
thank all of our speakers today for
sharing
their insights and for such an exciting
session and for all our to all our
participants for attending today's
session for asking your questions
and for being part of this so we hope to
see you in the upcoming program
and thank you again for attending today
um babe sir before we go is there
another free
webinar before the 29th
uh yes uh on january 25th i suppose yeah
okay all right yes sending out those
details
uh uh via email to everyone
so that if you're already
uh you know already registered via this
link you will get
all the details and if you're not
registered already to just get program
updates related to bioinformatics for
infectious disease again
please go ahead and just register here
and we will be sending you all the
updates once we have your details
all right well thank you again thank you
nine uh you can completely fill up the
scholarship form and we will be reaching
out to you
so thank you again for any other
questions please reach out to
marketing at pine.bio and i would end
today's session thank you everyone
have a nice week ahead